so we're back from Thanksgiving and
whether you did the Black Friday
shopping thing or you did the Black
Friday don't buy anything thing that's
what I did I actually have something for
you starting today that I think you're
really going to like and it's not
something you're going to throw out
after two days it's something you will
actually use for an entire year the year
of 2018 we have done David Pakman show
calendars for years we did a 2015
calendar we did a 2016 calendar we did a
2017 calendar each time with greater and
greater success and a few weeks ago I
mentioned I don't really have plans to
do one for 2018 things have been so
hectic we've been dealing with YouTube D
monetization we lost our Amazon
affiliate link I started the patreon a
fundraiser I'm teaching at Boston
College it's just been way too hectic to
do a calendar haven't even had time to
think about it but I received a bunch of
emails from people saying David when
will the 2018 calendars be available I
really want a 2018 calendar and I can
tell you that thanks to the great work
of three david pakman show viewers Dan
Burke Corey top kiss and Anthony Petra
mala who has helped with the calendar by
the way since the first year we did at
the 2015 calendar the 2018 David Pakman
show calendar is now available this is
the cover which we're showing you and on
the cover you see cartoon if occations
of me Donald Trump Steve Bannon Kelly
Ann Conway and Vladimir Putin and it is
all original artwork and it is such I
actually believe this may be the best
calendar yet because over time we get a
better and better sense of what makes a
good calendar and there's a couple of
options for getting it all of them are
available at david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 now let me just restate
because sometimes we have issues with
this it's david pakman.com slash
calendar 1 h not Calendar 2018 ok david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 couple of
options and you'll see them on the
website david pakman.com slash calendar
18 number 1 you can get the calendar
with a yearly membership for free ok
it's got to be a yearly membership and
you have to use the link
at david pakman.com slash calendar 818
if you use that option if you get the
calendar for free with a membership it
comes autographed automatically for free
now if you just want the calendar
there's also a link to that at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 you can get
just the calendar either autographed for
a little bit more it's a fundraiser
after all come on play along or not
autographed and free shipping within the
United States International shipping is
extra now a common question is if you
already have a membership what do you do
well you can decide if you've just
created a yearly membership you might
say oh I'll just get the calendar alone
and there's a Members Only discount for
the calendar which we'll talk about on
the bonus show and you can decide to go
about it that way or if you're like on a
monthly membership or your yearly
membership may be is almost over you can
cancel your existing membership restart
your membership and get the calendar for
free the art is really really great
Dan Burke did his great original
cartoons we have one example that we're
showing our television audience these
are completely original some of them
involve David Pakman as a character this
particular strip I've grown a big beard
and there's a whole storyline behind
that it's really really good stuff Corey
top kiss also did some really great art
including one piece that sort of Andy
Warhol esque which was then modified by
Anthony Pett ramallah edited it and and
built upon and it's a really really
funny and good calendar so check it out
david pakman.com slash calendar 18 a
real conversation starter I assure you
if you put this thing up on your fridge
if you have people who go to your house
sometimes or inside your office or your
cubicle people write to me and they say
I have a lot of conservative people that
work with me and they walk by my cubicle
and they see my camp calendar and it
looks interesting so they get closer and
they start looking at it and I just see
their faces drop because of all the
liberal propaganda on the calendar yeah
I mean the holidays are coming up too
what a better gift then to give your
supporting family members these make
perfect gifts actually for Trump
supporting family members and and really
for anybody it's a great gift so please
check it out david pakman
slash calendar 18 the audience is bigger
than ever this year than it's been in
the past so so speaking merely
mathematically we should be able to sell
more calendars than ever before